uh
this one the blind eye archer yes he's
uh he's a gentleman
um who's trying to uh you know get the
icp love there
okay and then look hey she did go on a
date this weekend
and it might have been him i don't know
we'll see what animal costume is he in
uh oh i'm gonna say turtle
she's an amazing friend to me and we
talk
more often than i than i usually thought
he would oh no
is he uh maybe oh
ah another bottle glasses
i have uh two two videos for you
afterwards but don't play them until
you're
uh bored with this okay holy [ __ ] these
glasses are even worse loving
she's sweet she's caring i don't see the
thickness
royce he sings i don't know if you've
heard him sing no is it good
oh it's really good i mean this is
fantastic
because i knew she wanted me to keep
going it looks like there are glasses
in his glasses yeah so much hope
it tries to be insane how much she cares
yeah i've seen him watch my back more
times than i can if you take some offer
they're just little dots like milhouse
kind of oh this is the oh this is also
an anime black because you see
i see naruto in the back trust me
sam hyde really disappears into his
character it's crazy how deep he goes
into it
oh no they're going out those are
corrective glasses
you gotta you gotta play him like he
professes his [ __ ] love in this video
sir
and i can't imagine my life without her
anymore oh my god
i'm just gonna sell you this boy she's
gonna do better she's changed my life
and i'm really happy for that
wicked amanda love changed his life
can't imagine my life without her don't
worry you'll smell her on your fingers
everywhere you go forever
and i i sent you one of his favorite
songs to sing is what he says
okay he has professed his love for
amanda
wickedlove hey guys what's up he's
saying he's got a great singing voice
royce get ready
this is good [ __ ] yes it's beautiful now
how big the lenses are i'm still
obviously got a few songs i want to
get off my chest so i hope you like them
no he's black herbert
[Music]
to be fair i think it's just he doesn't
want to wake up his parents
hi everyone welcome to day wave um
[Music]
he's a strong black man i don't know why
y'all making fun of him he's about to
get a date
oh guys we got we have a boy band this
is great yeah
i'll be the bear to him but you still
gotta whisper the baritone
[Music]
there it is
oh god no
no baby hair with a woman's eyes
i see you watching through the night
all over me
hi wait for
[Music]
everyone in chat give us back the clip
show
too bad we're back fellas don't this is
the worst stuff
[Music]
it's really good i don't know why you
already making your requests frozen
he's got seven subs he's lighting it up
man
oh [ __ ]
baby come back oh yeah yeah michael b
has a good point scratch the mic
on me there's something
everything about you
okay let's hear him this is going to be
better than ours
we're fooling around we're new boot
goofing he's he's going to be good
[Music]
archer keep it down in there your
father's trying to sleep
get me crazy
good morning oh my god oh my god hold on
oh my god he's singing jet lag by simple
plan
i typed in some of the news nice good
song
no good song good song
i like it out of all of them too
yeah he is i can hear it oh no i'm gonna
sing along
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyway love you guys they're calling him
simple plan
oh no oh so he was
he he was singing that song for wicked
love
and wicked love had a date i don't know
i sent you the other two ridges
all right wicked love had a date right
got to go out
all right i gotta say it it went well
for her
we could love had a date so which one
which one would uh chilling with my
boyfriend
chill with my boyfriend maybe he's a
better singer
we're watching paradise p.d
i take back what we said before i i
don't like paradise pd anymore
that's a big arm you know i don't know
if that was
you know hey jj what's up buddy uh so
that guy professing his love to her
he was a skinny small guy right uh he
has leg braces yes
wait what wait wait wait wait wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
he asked if he was just any skinny small
guy and you answered by saying
he has leg braces yes
that's not the only question he asked he
asked if he was skinny
and he replied with yes he has leg
braces
well i mean i know this because he
literally
has a video where he says how i walk
can we see that one please that's his
arm i got you
there it is how i walk royce
please but yeah his arm that might be
his arm i don't know
no i let's see if it's his arm
well you know what let's let's uh
let's let's see because i have another
video so let's see if it's his arm this
might be him
oh no that is not him
no that's oh that's that's that's cousin
joe's co-host
oh dad
that's cousin hey can you throw a new
jersey devil's hat backwards on the back
of his head
it'll be [ __ ] perfect buffalo wild
wings of redemption
[Laughter]
okay hold on this is how he walks
he's got his uh leg braces oh i feel bad
now
and he's blind so he can't walk you
can't see
that explains why he likes her yeah
doesn't it
oh [ __ ] like an egyptian
[ __ ] like an egyptian
[ __ ] fight a man talk like a man
i'm walking on sunshine
um yeah i
pretty much use this cane right here
for like like support and everything
like this is the game i use
i had it for years but oh god really
it's a
it's a gandalf one i know i i am feel
i feel bad for him um
but come on dude even you could do
better
than [ __ ] amanda love yes oh my god
maybe you know we can swerve it and get
frozen off the hook to [ __ ] your dress
no
stop this why do you want to stop me
trying to not get you laid back
oh that's what you just did i thought
you wanted me to talk now continue
continue on i'm listening now
oh never mind oh no you're frozen frozen
said he wants the [ __ ] that's fine
now he didn't
god damn it so close frozen you almost
had an hour you're almost out of now but
guess what
here we are you did it all right let's
let's go back to gandalf the black
because there are days where i'm walking
with it and
i'm in a lot of pain because of how much
i have to walk
i'm a lot of faith this is
how i feel i'm cold and i'm ashamed
i naked on the floor
i'm okay i just take it day by day
[Music]
wake me up wake me up
[Laughter]
by the way he has seven subs let's fix
this all right this guy needs to be
encouraged i agree
much content as possible i'll post a
link i got you on the link too
he should have at least 50 subs by the
time i start my shopko
i tear myself open i saw myself shut
my weaknesses i walk
too much we need to get him on
and just have karaoke night i'm gonna
fix it i could fix him
fix him oh god i mean obviously not his
not his his walking but his personality
i could definitely fix his personality
not your legs don't get your hopes up
bud your legs i can't fix that
but personality i got you bud hey i know
who could fix his legs
do you know who could fix his legs hmm
who
a certain um pastor
maybe that's right maybe pastor royce
could heal his legs
get you my wife gertrude as big as
amanda love buddy i know why you fall in
love with them big women it's the credit
score
all right um not with that one that's a
very good point
uh a.g clip this hi future royce in the
later best of
um oh wait let me let me do this for the
future voice wow
people that are watching this and it's
totally live look at all the things
you're saying in the chat
perfect set it up you saw how i set that
up
oh wow miami milf said something stupid
in the chat that'll play for any replay
because she's always saying stupid
things
so it's actually gonna work yes can i
advocate for
uh the silence to be replaced with dog
squeakies
cause it was ducks and then he did the
silas thing i think it needs to be a
squeaky
so that it pisses the dogs off yeah
every time someone says [ __ ] [ __ ] or
it just goes squeaky squeaky squeaky
it'll piss the dogs off it'll be great